The joe rogan experience,
but there's no way of getting a New York City less.
You pay him some money.
You want to take those bridges from Staten Island,
you can pay me,
bitch,
you're coming in from Jersey,
pay me.
You got to pay to get in here dog.
It's like an amusing because it cost anything to leave.
It doesn't Cost York and deleted all of my funds.
And uh,
both times when I moved out of New York,
I,
as I crossed the free bridge,
I thought it doesn't cost anything to leave.
Isn't that fascinating?
It's,
is it to regulate how many people come in and is it to mitigate traffic and to
make it like problematic because it cost so much money.
Maybe a Carpool.
Is that the idea?
To tell you a little story?
Sure.
To me,
and they won.
It is a big story actually,
and I was reminded of,
but you're talking about the George Washington Bridge and when I was 20 years
old,
I lived in Washington heights for a year.
Worst Year of my life.
Why?
Just the worst year of my life.
I,
I wasn't ready as a comedian.
Um,
how old were you?
20.
Oh yeah.
I'd only been doing it like three years.
I,
you know,
I didn't have been doing it three years by the time I started at 17 Beta.
We're just start Orlando powerful and Lando produced a couple of good things and
uh,
anyway,
so
I always swore if I ever had any money I would live in New York was style.
So when my Sitcom was finished,
a 98,
99,
I moved to New York City and I got a rock star apartment in the Wall Street
area.
Oh,
you did not consider it.
One of the first skyscrapers ever built a 20 stories tall.
It's at the entrance of a were Wall Street.
The entrance of Wall Street.
It's trinity churches.
Right?
They're only on the 18th floor.
Where there marble balconies?
I had three marble balconies.
I was on this corner unit,
just pimp spot.
Oh my God.
Three blocks from the World Trade Center.
Oh my goodness.
16 foot tall.
I could lie in my bed.
Look up at the World Trade Center.
Must've been insane.
It was,
it was fantastic,
but it was a time in my life,
you know,
the Sitcom had ended.
I,
I felt I was angry.
I was angry and I was,
I was,
I was searching for meaning and,
and uh,
what was important in life and what was making you angry?
I just,
you know,
that I had the Sitcom and it didn't work out.
And then I just,
you know,
I wanted to just go focus on being a comedian and live in New York.
So the Dalai Lama was going to give a speech for free in central park on
happiness for six months.
I had the flyer on my refrigerator.
Nothing in the world was going to make me miss the Dalai Lama's speech on
happiness.
So the night before,
I'm headlining at Caroline's on Broadway and there were these two Puerto Rican
lesbian strippers and they loved me and they stuck around after the show and
they wanted to talk to me and we're high,
we're talking.
And then they,
they invited me out with them and know what,
uh,
there was the queen bee and the other girl,
the other girl was off limits because she had a boyfriend.
I ain't give a fuck about the other girl.
It was all about the queen bee and the other girl was in love with the Queen
Bee.
Cause she's making all the,
all the decisions and making everything happen.
Wow.
So she,
the Queen Bee had a car.
We're driving down to the village somewhere.
Uh,
they said they had ecstasy.
Do I want to do ecstasy?
And I'm like,
hell yeah.
We go to some lounge and we're drinking Pinot Grigio on ice.
And I had never had Pinot Grigio.
My mother and I,
and to this day,
I love Pino Grigio cause it reminds me of this evening.
It's a perfect,
uh,
you know,
like red wine.
Is it all,
you know,
autumn,
winter thing.
Uh,
but,
but a dry white wine,
like a Pinot Grigio is great in summer.
So we're in,
you know,
we're drinking and we're having a great time.
And,
uh,
you know,
after about an hour,
this ecstasy starts thumping and this girl,
the queen bee wanted to go to some dance club.
We go to some dance club in Soho.
It's packed.
I didn't want to be a packed dance club.
I want to be with these girls.
She knew the DJ.
We get up these steps were in this private area behind the DJ.
No one can see us,
the Djs like 10,
15 feet in front of us just like jamming and the place is packed downstairs but
you can't see them.
And we got this horse shoe leather couch and we're just rocking and she's got
more bottles of Pinot Grigio and ice and we're just fucking dancing and grinding
on each other.
And we go back to my apartment and about five o'clock in the morning,
something like that.
And you know,
we dance on my furniture and we'll play music and stuff and we got in my bed and
honestly there was no sex.
Uh,
we had our bottoms underwear on and it was so tender and just resting and
kissing and tasting of fleshing and touching of private areas.
And the,
at one point the queen bee got up on her knees and she starts French kissing
this other girl and she's rubbing her mound.
What?
She's just kissing her.
And I got behind this,
uh,
behind the Queen Bee and I just start kissing this big beautiful brown bulbous
acid.
Hmm.
I got my hands up on the top curvature of it and I pulled her panties aside,
them stuck my nose in our honeypot and I'm just tasting these delicious flesh
rose petals and,
um,
I overslept and I missed the Dalai Lama's speech.
When you,
when you,
why would you,
why would you even think that that would be a bad thing?
The Dalai Lama is a true story,
but it's not a joke.
It's actually a true story story.
The Dalai Lama represents a,
an interesting point of view and that's it.
You know,
the idea that this guy's guy for define what happiness is.
The I,
it's the idea of a one uh,
one figurehead like that is kind of preposterous to the idea of enlightenment.
The idea,
especially if you're dealing with a guy who dresses like a wizard and doesn't
fuck.